[Music]
is he on salary medication - well he's
definitely some list to eat where's that
panty on us here over here the therapist
I like that guy though I like j-rod do
dick pics tricky tricky game also you
gotta get the right angle the lighting
even a small dick if you got that big
dick energy it's easy take it from
anywhere you have to small dick energy
it's all about the angles bro the
lighting grease it up get creative yeah
maybe put some put draw some eyes on it
you know I'm saying put a little fur
coat on it or sometime used to do this
trick you'd get like if you caught a
small fish you put it in the back of
like a little remote-control truck and
you take a picture like oh I caught this
big fish oh that's dope so that's what I
could do did a micro machine yeah make
your dick look like anime you dick over
the top of it put some rope on it yeah
that's a great idea dude like dang gotta
get creative man yeah awesome eyes on it
I like what I like to do from time to
time is I like to take the wrapper from
a Cadbury egg just put over the tip of
your dick oh yeah yeah yeah do that old
like it's like war war one do that old
hochiminh kind of attack sort of thing
when they had the those special hats
are you talking about d-day there's also
great I am I think so dude well there's
also like the Trojan horse move you know
I'm saying oh yeah yeah but you want to
hype it up cuz then when when you what
is that one is that the one where you
hide in somebody's yard throw a bunch of
semen through their window you could or
you just kind of put it over the sheets
and you just you know you get the good
angle and it's just like open the sheets
so it looks like it's a Trojan horse but
really it's just about all taking that
yeah you'll be all right dude damn
Jim brought up Trojan horse I've even
lonely out on that he's dead left shrimp
Jersey look at this pizza had my son
[ __ ] cartoon take a picture let's see
who that guy is modeling the plugged
yeah cuz his goal is to become a serious
actor this is the only gig this man got
you got a [ __ ] you see you could buy a
small one of those and put around your
dick though oh yeah if you had a fun hat
on your dick dude ranch hat hey your
dick black make it look like a moray eel
put it in a tank put put put it put it
well with some [ __ ] Bubble Guppies
and my wiener kind of looks like a fat
asian guy with us one of those hats on
can you Google fat guy with hat Asian
yeah uh you dick looks like Chef
Boyardee Chef Boyardee Dom chef bore a
cockatiel yeah my dick looks just like
that dude I say Korean - oh he is Korean
of course he is it a very Korean kind of
dick area you know looks soft though you
know like nice oh yeah yeah no idea dude
here's the thing with dictators is my
dad here's the thing with dick pics
make sure when you do blast it out it's
a good one cuz if it does leak you want
it to be like oh my god I can't believe
they posted that yeah you don't want a
bad dick pic get out there make sure if
you're gonna send it
that thing's flawless yeah that's the
only advice I got for you
yeah and I've also you know I know a guy
named Jason Tebow he's a comedian and he
on neat guy you know he wears like
different shirts and stuff every time I
see him and he um he let me use his dick
for a couple years deep pigs and I paid
him like $40 for two dick pics and I
would use those were they dude rented
yeah that's not bad business rent a dick
so everyone's like oh my god sure they
were good man he [ __ ] had a cigarette
burn on the edge
but that wasn't my style but that's him
right there that's my boy
he had that very kind of like he had
that Renaissance Fair looking kind of
dead he had the battle dick like he was
the front senator like I dig it like it
he just eaten a big turkey leg and maybe
want to you know wanted a little
jousting know right well good on but it
was also maybe gonna paint this
afternoon
total Ren Faire type of wine rent a dick
bro I say if you're gonna send them they
better be good but in general price yeah
I'm gonna sting the ax man I think yeah
take care yeah show your dick in person
dude do the old fashioned run up show
you a dick real fast and run off yeah we
caught flashing yeah
[Music]
the King nothing
[Music]